- Hello.
Now, when you look at me right now,
you probably think that it's
me, Sal, talking to you.
But really what is talking to you
is a society
of over 30 trillion cells
that have somehow
collectively convinced itself
that it is Sal.
And what we're going to
study in these lessons
are exactly that,
that even though we think
we're one unified organism,
or frankly, all the
living things we see are,
we say oh, that's a
plant, and that's a frog,
and that's a pigeon, and that's a Sal.
It's not just a Sal.
It's made up of trillions
and trillions of things called cells,
which as we'll learn,
they're the fundamental
building blocks of life.
What makes them alive,
and if we were to go at
a even more basic scale,
all of a sudden things are not alive.
It's a fascinating philosophical question.
And you might think that
one thirty-trillionth of me
might be some kind of small, simple thing,
but as we'll see there's a
whole universe in each cell.
Unimaginable complexity that scientists
are still trying to understand.
In these lessons we're gonna talk about
the history of mankind trying to struggle
with the basic units of life.
Is there a basic unit,
and how do we understand how it works,
also known as cell theory.
We're going to learn about
the different types of cells
that even exist,
things like prokaryatic
and eukaryotic cells.
Things like plant and animal cells,
what's similar, what's different?
And finally, we're gonna
learn about parts of the cell,
especially things like, say, the membrane,
which in and of itself is a fascinating
and complex piece of machinery.
So, we're about to delve into
some of the deepest ideas
that mankind has always faced.
What is life?
What makes one thing alive
and another thing not alive?
What is the most basic unit of life?
Where did it come from?
We're gonna touch on all of
those in the next few lessons.
And I encourage, if you wanna dive deeper
and get more context,
and get practice to make sure
that you're understanding these concepts,
look at these lessons on khanacademy.org.